Hi, I'm John Green, this is Crash Course U.S.
History, and today, we're going to talk about slavery,
which is not funny.
Yeah, so we put a lei on the eagle to
try and cheer you up, but let's face it, this
is going to be depressing.
With slavery, every time you think, like,
"Aw, it couldn't have been that bad," it turns
out to have been much worse.
Mr. Green, Mr. Green! But what about –
Yeah, Me from the Past, I'm going to stop you right
there, because you're going to embarrass yourself.
Slavery was hugely important to America.
I mean, it led to a civil war and it also lasted what,
at least in U.S. history, counts as a long-ass time,
from 1619 to 1865.
And yes, I know there's a 1200-year-old church
in your neighborhood in Denmark, but we're not
talking about Denmark!
But slavery is most important because we still
struggle with its legacy.
So, yes, today's episode will probably not
be funny, but it will be important.
[Theme Music]
So the slave-based economy in the South is
sometimes characterized as having been separate from
the Market Revolution, but that's not really the case.
Without southern cotton, the North wouldn't have been
able to industrialize, at least not as quickly, because
cotton textiles were one of the first industrially products.
And the most important commodity in world trade
by the nineteenth century, and 3/4 of the world's
cotton came from the American South.
And speaking of cotton, why has no one mentioned
to me that my collar has been half popped this entire
episode, like I'm trying to recreate the Flying Nun's hat.
And although there were increasingly fewer slaves
in the North as northern states outlawed slavery,
cotton shipments overseas made northern
merchants rich.
Northern bankers financed the purchase of
land for plantations.
Northern insurance companies insured slaves
who were, after all, considered property, and
very valuable property.
And in addition to turning cotton into cloth
for sale overseas, northern manufacturers
sold cloth back to the South,
where it was used to clothe the very slaves
who had cultivated it.
But certainly the most prominent effects of
the slave-based economy were seen in the South.
The profitability of slaved-based agriculture,
especially King Cotton, meant that the South
would remain largely agricultural and rural.
Slave states were home to a few cities, like
St. Louis and Baltimore, but with the exception
of New Orleans,
almost all southern urbanization took place in the upper
South, further away from the large cotton plantations.
And slave-based agriculture was so profitable
that it siphoned money away from other economic
endeavors.
Like, there was very little industry in the
South.
It produced only 10% of the nation's manufactured
goods.
And, as most of the capital was being plowed into
the purchase of slaves, there was very little room for
technological innovation, like, for instance, railroads.
This lack of industry and railroads would
eventually make the South suck at the Civil
War, thankfully.
In short, slavery dominated the South, shaping
it both economically and culturally, and slavery
wasn't a minor aspect of American society.
By 1860, there were four million slaves in
the U.S., and in the South, they made up one
third of the total population.
Although in the popular imagination, most plantations
were these sprawling affairs with hundreds of slaves,
in reality, the majority of slaveholders
owned five or fewer slaves.
And, of course, most white people in the South owned
no slaves at all, though, if they could afford to, they
would sometimes rent slaves to help with their work.
These were the so-called yeoman farmers who
lived self-sufficiently, raised their own food, and
purchased very little in the Market Economy.
They worked the poorest land and, as a result,
were mostly pretty poor themselves.
But even they largely supported slavery,
partly, perhaps, for aspirational reasons,
and partly because the racism inherent to the system
gave even the poorest whites legal and social status.
And southern intellectuals worked hard to
encourage these ideas of white solidarity
and to make the case for slavery.
Many of the founders, a bunch of whom you'll remember,
held slaves, saw slavery as a necessary evil.
Jefferson once wrote, quote, "As it is, we
have the wolf by the ear, and we can neither
hold him, nor safely let him go.
Justice is on one scale, and self-preservation
in the other."
The belief that justice and self-preservation
couldn't sit on the same side of the scale
was really opposed to the American idea,
and, in the end, it would make the Civil War inevitable.
But as slavery became more entrenched in
these ideas of liberty and political equality were
embraced by more people,
some southerners began to make the case
that slavery wasn't just a necessary evil.
They argued, for instance, that slaves benefited
from slavery.
Because, you know, because their masters fed
them and clothed them and took care of them
in their old age.
You still hear this argument today, astonishingly.
In fact, you'll probably see asshats in the
comments saying that in the comments.
I will remind you, it's not cursing if you
are referring to an actual ass.
This paternalism allowed masters to see themselves
as benevolent and to contrast their family-oriented
slavery with the cold, mercenary Capitalism
of the free-labor North.
So yeah, in the face of rising criticism of
slavery, some southerners began to argue that the
institution was actually good for the social order.
One of the best-known proponents of this view
was John C. Calhoun, who, in 1837, said this
in a speech on the Senate floor:
"I hold that, in the present state of civilization,
where two races of different origin and
distinguished by color and other physical differences
as well as intellectual, are brought together,
the relation now existing in the slave-holding states
between the two is, instead of an evil, a good.
A positive good."
Now, of course, John C. Calhoun was a fringe
politician, and nobody took his views particularly
seriously.
Stan: Well, he was Secretary of State from
1844 to 1845.
John: Well, I mean, who really cares about
the Secretary of State, Stan?
Danica: Eh, he was also Secretary of War from
1817 to 1825.
John: All right, but we don't even have a Secretary
of War anymore, so...
Meredith: And he was Vice President from 1825
to 1832.
John: Oh my god, were we insane?!
We were, of course, but we justified the insanity
with Biblical passages and with the examples
of the Greeks and Romans,
and with outright racism, arguing that black
people were inherently inferior to whites.
And that not to keep them in slavery would
upset the natural order of things.
A worldview popularized millennia ago by my
nemesis, Aristotle.
God, I hate Aristotle.
You know what defenders of Aristotle always
say?
"He was the first person to identify dolphins."
Well, ok, dolphin identifier.
Yes, that is what he should be remembered
for, but he's a terrible philosopher!
Here's the truth about slavery:
It was coerced labor that relied upon intimidation
and brutality and dehumanization.
And this wasn't just a cultural system, it
was a legal one.
I mean, Louisiana law proclaimed that a slave
"owes his master... a respect without bounds,
and an absolute obedience."
The signal feature of slaves' lives was work.
I mean, conditions and tasks varied, but all
slaves labored, usually from sunup to sundown,
and almost always without any pay.
Most slaves worked in agriculture on plantations,
and conditions were different, depending on
which crops are grown.
Like, slaves on the rice plantations of South
Carolina had terrible working conditions,
but they labored under the task system, which meant
that once they had completed their allotted daily work,
they would have time to do other things.
But lest you imagine this is like how we have
work and leisure time, bear in mind that they
were owned and treated as property.
On cotton plantations, most slaves worked
in gangs, usually under the control of an overseer,
or another slave who was called a "driver."
This was back-breaking work done in the southern sun
and humidity, and so it's not surprising that whippings –
– or the threat of them –  were often
necessary to get slaves to work.
It's easy enough to talk about the brutality of slave
discipline, but it can be difficult to internalize it.
Like, you look at these pictures, but because
you've seen them over and over again, they don't
have the power they once might have.
The pictures can tell a story about cruelty,
but they don't necessarily communicate how
arbitrary it all was.
As, for example, in this story, told by a
woman who was a slave as a young girl:
"[The] overseer... went to my father one morning
and said, "Bob, I'm gonna whip you this morning."
Daddy said, "I ain't done nothing," and he
said, "I know it, I'm going to whip you to
keep you from doing nothing,"
and he hit him with that cowhide – you know
it would cut the blood out of you with every lick
if they hit you hard."
That brutality – the whippings, the brandings,
the rape – was real, and it was intentional,
because, in order for slavery to function,
slaves had to be dehumanized.
This enabled slaveholders to rationalize what
they were doing, and it was hoped to reduce
slaves to the animal property that is implied
by the term "chattel slavery."
So the idea was that slaveholders wouldn't
think of their slaves as human, and slaves
wouldn't think of themselves as human.
But it didn't work.
Let's go to the Thought Bubble.
Slaves' resistance to their dehumanization
took many forms, but the primary way was by
forming families.
Family was a refuge for slaves and a source of
dignity that masters recognized and sought to stifle.
A paternalistic slave owner named Bennet H. Barrow
wrote in his rules for the Highland Plantation:
"No rule that I have stated is of more
importance than that relating to Negroes
marrying outside of the plantation...
It creates a feeling of independence."
Most slaves did marry, usually for life, and,
when possible, slaves grew up in two-parent
households.
Single-parent households were common, though,
as a result of one parent being sold.
In the upper South, where the economy was
shifting from tobacco to different, less labor-intensive
cash crops, the sale of slaves was common.
Perhaps one-third of slave marriages in states
like Virginia were broken up by sale.
Religion was also an important part of life
in slavery.
While masters wanted their slaves to learn
the parts of the Bible that talked about being
happy in bondage,
slave worship tended to focus on the stories of Exodus,
where Moses brought the slaves out of bondage,
or Biblical heroes, who overcame great
odds, like Daniel and David.
And, although most slaves were forbidden to
learn to read and write, many did anyway.
And some became preachers.
Slave preachers were often very charismatic
leaders, and they roused the suspicion of
slave owners, and not without reason.
Two of the most important slave uprisings
in the South were led by preachers.
Thanks, Thought Bubble.
Oh, it's time for the Mystery Document?
We're doing two set pieces in a row? All right.
[buzzing noise] [music]
The rules here are simple.
I wanted to re-shoot that, but Stan said no.
I guess the author of the Mystery Document.
If I am wrong, I get shocked with the shock
pen.
"Since I have been in the Queen's dominions
I have been well contented, yes well contented
for sure, man is as God intended he should be.
That is, all are born free and equal.
This is a wholesome law, not like the southern
laws which puts man made in the image of God
on level with brutes.
O, what will become of the people, and where
will they stand in the day of judgment.
Would that the 5th verse of the 3rd chapter
of Malachi were written as with a bar of iron,
and the point of a diamond upon every
oppressor's heart that they might repent of this
evil, and let the oppressed go free..."
All right, it's definitely a preacher, because
only preachers have read Malachi.
Probably African American, probably not someone
from the South.
I'm going to guess that it is Richard Allen,
the founder of the African Methodist Episcopal
Church?
[buzzing noise]
DAAAH, DANG IT!
It's Joseph Taper, and Stan just pointed out
to me that I should have known it was Joseph
Taper because it starts out,
"Since I have been in the Queen's dominions..."
He was in Canada. He escaped slavery to
Canada. The Queen's dominions!
All right, Canadians, I blame you for this,
although, thank you for abolishing slavery
decades before we did.
[electric sounds] AHHH!
So, the Mystery Document shows one of the
primary ways that slaves resisted their oppression:
by running away.
Although some slaves like Joseph Taper escaped
for good by running away to northern free states,
or even to Canada, where they wouldn't
have to worry about fugitive slave laws,
even more slaves ran away temporarily, hiding out
in the woods or the swamps, and eventually returning.
No one knows exactly how many slaves escaped
to freedom, but the best estimate is that a thousand
or so a year made the journey northward.
Most fugitive slaves were young men, but the
most famous runaway has been hanging out behind
me all day long: Harriet Tubman.
Harriet Tubman escaped to Philadelphia at
the age of 29, and over the course of her life,
she made about 20 trips back to Maryland
to help friends and relatives make the journey
north on the Underground Railroad.
But a more dramatic form of resistance to
slavery was actual, armed rebellion, which
was attempted.
Now, individuals sometimes took matters into
their own hands and beat or even killed their
white overseers or masters.
Like Bob, the guy who received the arbitrary
beating, responded to it by killing his overseer
with a hoe.
But that said, large-scale slave uprisings
were relatively rare.
The four most famous ones all took place in a
35-year period at the beginning of the 19th century.
Gabriel's Rebellion in 1800 – which we've
talked about before – was discovered before
he was able to carry out his plot.
Then, in 1811, a group of slaves upriver from
New Orleans seized cane, knives, and guns, and
marched on the city before militia stopped them.
And in 1822, Denmark Vesey, a former slave
who had purchased his freedom, may have organized
a plot to destroy Charleston, South Carolina.
I say "may have" because the evidence against him
is disputed and comes from a trial that was not fair.
But regardless, the end result of that trial
was that he was executed, as were 34 slaves.
But the most successful slave rebellion, at
least in the sense that they actually killed some
people, was Nat Turner's in August 1831.
Turner was a preacher, and with a group of
about 80 slaves, he marched from farm to farm
in South Hampton County, Virginia,
killing the inhabitants, most of whom were women
and children, because the men were attending a
religious revival meeting in North Carolina.
Turner and 17 other rebels were captured and
executed, but not before they struck terror into the
hearts of whites all across the American South.
Virginia's response was to make slavery worse,
passing even harsher laws that forbade slaves from
preaching, and prohibited teaching them to read.
Other slave states followed Virginia's lead and, by
the 1830s, slavery had grown, if anything, more harsh.
So, this shows that large-scaled armed
resistance was – Django Unchained aside –
not just suicidal, but also a threat to loved
ones and, really, to all slaves.
But, it is hugely important to emphasize that
slaves did resist their oppression.
Sometimes this meant taking up arms, but usually
it meant more subtle forms of resistance,
like intentional work slowdowns or sabotaging
equipment, or pretending not to understand instructions.
And, most importantly, in the face of systematic
legal and cultural degradation, they re-affirmed
their humanity through family and through faith.
Why is this so important?
Because too often in America, we still talk
about slaves as if they failed to rise up,
when, in fact, rising up would not have made
life better for them or for their families.
The truth is, sometimes carving out an identity as a human being in a social order that is constantly seeking to dehumanize you, is the most powerful form of resistance.
Refusing to become the chattel that their masters believed them to be is what made slavery untenable and the Civil War inevitable, so make no mistake, slaves fought back.
And in the end, they won.
I'll see you next week.
Crash Course is produced and directed by Stan
Muller.
The script supervisor is Meredith Danko.
Our associate producer is Danica Johnson.
The show is written by my high school history
teacher Raoul Meyer and myself.
And our graphics team is Thought Cafe.
Every week, there's a new caption to the Libertage,
but today's episode was so sad that we couldn't
fit a Libertage in...
UNTIL NOW!
[Libertage Rock Music]
Suggest Libertage caption in comments, where
you can also ask questions about today's video that
will be answered by our team of historians.
Thanks for watching Crash Course, and as we
say in my home town, don't forget to be abolitionist.